amnesty international exhorte à nouveau
dôme hayden a abandonné les poursuites
contre julian assange décharge à
motivation politique selon les ong
l'appel a été lancé à la veille d'une
nouvelle audience elle se tient
aujourd'hui au royaume uni la justice
britannique examine l'appel des
etats-unis contre la décision de ne pas
extrader le fondateur de wikileaks en
janvier dernier un juge britannique
avait estimé que la santé mentale de
gene vincent j'étais trop fragile à ses
soutiens sont une fois de plus mobilisés
parmi lesquels jérémy corps been
l'ancien chef du parti travailliste
britannique on écoute
mais je ne veux pas que l'internet soit
investie par des racistes ou des
empoisonneurs qui peuvent par leur
comportement de troll causé un énorme
préjudice particulièrement aux jeunes
le journalisme est menacée cela
provenant de deux sources l'une c'est
l'oppression des journalistes par l'état
qui a cours dans beaucoup de pays du
monde ce qui s'y passe est limpide mais
ce qui représente également une menace
c'est ce péril par exemple des
entreprises de mass médias qui ont un
contrôle énorme sur les organes de
presse télé radio et presse écrite il en
émerge une sorte d'autocensure à l'égard
du comportement journalistique et c'est
tout autant dangereux
[Musique]
qui est en jeu pour les états unis
l'occasion de lancer un avertissement
selon vincent berger avocat au barreau
de paris ancien jurisconsulte de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme écoutez
une affaire qui est à la fois judiciaire
mais aussi politique évidemment vu le
retentissement mondial qu'a eue
le tout s'est tu sais ces transferts
d'informations parler parler wikileaks
donc le monde entier en fait est
intéressé par cette affaire
mais il va de soi que les
services secrets américains généralement
les gouvernements des états unis
d'amérique veulent en quelque sorte
pouvoir condamner assange sans doute
aussi pour non seulement pour le punir
de ce qu'il a fait
mais aussi pour être pour donner un
avertissement à tous ceux qui dans le
monde seraient tentés de suivre son
exemple un exemple qui d'ailleurs a déjà
été suivi dans certaines parties du
monde mais pour des affaires sans doute
moins politique je pense notamment à des
affaires fiscales ou bancaires